[Aplausos]
[Música]
el Estado peruano en frente a difíciles
retos a corto y mediano plazo necesita
una nueva forma de hacer minería en su
territorio Pedro Castillo queridos
amigos amigas con esta frase el nuevo y
controvertido presidente del Perú quiso
dejar claras sus intenciones durante su
discurso de investidura una nueva forma
de hacer minería y no solo eso Pedro
Castillo ha prometido todo una
revolución política y también económica
para el país de esta forma por ejemplo
durante este mismo discurso inaugural
dejo también claro que a partir de ahora
el Estado peruano exigir a todos los
proyectos mineros industriales más
impuestos y también cumplir con un nuevo
criterio la rentabilidad social si un
proyecto no tiene rentabilidad social
simplemente no va
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es decir que para con proyecto sea
aprobado ya no solo tendrá que ser
rentable y pagar los impuestos
convenidos al Estado peruano y ahora
también tendrá que cumplir con otras
cuestiones como no sé dinamizar la
economía del entorno apoyar la cultura
lo que haga luego preservar el medio
ambiente lo que por otra parte pues ya
se supone que hacen con su actividad con
los impuestos que pagan y con las
regulaciones y normas que les exige el
estado bueno todo esto de la
rentabilidad social es algo que el
Gobierno tendrá que detallar
Pedro Castillo habla de rentabilidad
social
si el polo lo requiere y ojo porque
estamos hablando del sector más
importante de la economía peruana el
Perú es todo una potencia minera a nivel
mundial y solo los proyectos actualmente
en marcha suman decenas y decenas de
miles de millones de dólares y eso eso
ha hecho que me hizo al políticos
hagamos o unas cuantas preguntas qué
papel tiene realmente la minería en el
Perú porque Pedro Castillo ha puesto a
las minas en Laviana cómo es posible que
tanto rechazo social como este sector
configura el futuro del Perú y quizás la
pregunta más importante de todas qué es
exactamente lo que está en juego atento
[Música]
por cierto si quieres estar al tanto de
todo lo que ocurre en América Latina no
os perdáis Latam política dedicada
específicamente a la actualidad de
estación os dejamos todos los detalles
por aquí abajo la descripción
[Música]
minería en el Perú en busca y captura
una de las mayores potencias mineras de
todo el planeta por ejemplo según el
Servicio Geológico de Estados Unidos
anualmente una media de
25000000 de dólares en exportaciones
mineras lo que supone tal y como os
podéis imaginar una fuente de divisas
vital para la economía peruana y ahí ahí
no acaba todo
[Música]
el sector minero también emplea
directamente a unos 200.000 trabajadores
formales y se calcula que generen
directamente más de 1,3 millones de
puestos de trabajo adicionales entre
otras cosas porque los trabajos del
sector minero son más productivos y se
caracterizan por pagar salarios mucho
más altos algo más del doble que los
habituales en el resto de la economía
peruana
además luego tendríamos que tener en
cuenta a cerca de medio millón de
personas más que se calcula trabajan en
lo que se conoce como la minería
informal es decir la que se realiza de
forma ilegal o al margen de los permisos
y las regulaciones del Estado luego
hablaremos de ello resumiendo que para
la economía peruana la minería es casi
tan importante como lo son los huevos
para hacer una tortilla sin embargo echa
el freno porque todo ello Cali como
hemos visto el nuevo gobierno ha puesto
a esta industria en Laviana así que la
pregunta que todos podríamos hacernos es
porque demonios un gobierno se lanza la
yugular de una industria tan importante
para el país pues no penséis por un
instante que lo hace por casualidad o
por falta de vida en menos de mi las
políticas lo siento amigo es que la mía
es una industria terriblemente impopular
en el Perú porque pues por varios
motivos en primer lugar porque tiene
impacto muy pero que muy alto sobre el
terreno
cuenta kilómetros cuadrados y desde
luego no solo se trata del terreno
también necesita enormes cantidades de
agua zonas donde no pocos casos los
habitantes tiene seguir problemas de
suministro Lugo habitualmente el
trasiego de camiones y maquinaria
también afecta a la vida las cosechas ya
los pastos de las zonas rurales por la
gran cantidad de polvo que se levanta y
además si no se hacen bien las cosas el
riesgo de contaminación es muy alto con
series implicaciones incluso para la
salud de las personas
aún con todo el mayor problema del
primer número uno esa sensación que
tienen las comunidades rurales de estar
siendo robadas es decir que el enorme
negocio que las compañías mineras hacen
con las explotaciones en el no termina
traduciéndose en una mejor aclara sus
condiciones de vida y eso eso cuando no
experimentan directamente un perjuicio
ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de
Cajamarca y el hogar natal de Pedro
Castillo y la región más pobre de todo
el país a pesar de tener una potente
industria minera y muchísimo recursos
naturales por explotar pesadillo las
carreteras y las infraestructuras son
deplorables y casi la mitad de la
población se encuentra en situación de
pobreza severa
[Música]
y ojo porque hablando un sentimiento que
sigas teniendo lo largo y ancho de todo
el país especialmente en las regiones
mineras y todo esto es precisamente lo
que explica tantos y tantos conflictos
sociales por ejemplo según la Defensoría
del Pueblo tan solo durante el primer
trimestre del 2021 se registraron 80
conflictos activos relacionados con la
minería ahora bien que hay de verdad
tras todas estas acusaciones es cierto
que las mineras son tan irresponsables
es verdad que no pagan apenas impuestos
pues amigos como en toda buena historia
vamos a poder encontrar claroscuros
respecto al impacto ambiental y la
explotación laboral hay que decir que la
mayoría de los problemas están asociados
a la minería ilegal o a la mala praxis
de los funcionarios que tienen el deber
de controlar el cumplimiento de la
regulación establecida o perseguir las
explotaciones ilegales y ojo porque no
hablamos precisamente de cuestiones
menores fijado
[Música]
según estimaciones de la consultora
Macroconsult casi el 30% de toda la
producción de oro se llevó a cabo en
minas ilegales minas que por supuesto no
cumplen con las exigencias ambientales
ni de seguridad laboral ni de protección
de la salud pública ni absolutamente
nada de nada
y justo ahora llegamos a la cuestión
clave tiene razón Pedro Castillo y
tantos otros activistas y políticos
peruanos que denuncian que las
multinacionales me das apenas pagan
impuestos y es cierto que están
saqueando las riquezas del Perú por qué
demonios cuesta tanto ver avances
económicos en los entornos mineros
atento
[Música]
el dinero que nos llega
a ver es acaso cierto que las grandes
mineras apenas pagan impuestos en el
Perú pues para responder a esa pregunta
lo primero que tenemos que tener en
cuenta es que en el Perú la minería se
enfrenta varios impuestos principales
por un lado como cualquier otra empresa
al Impuesto a la Renta esto es al
impuesto sobre los beneficios pero luego
también tienen que hacer frente a las
regalías mineras al impuesto especial a
la minería ya gravamen especial a la
minería el resultado de todo ello es que
según cálculos del Instituto Peruano de
Economía las empresas mineras que operan
en el Perú se enfrentan a una carga
fiscal de al menos el
47,07% de sus beneficios lo que está por
encima del promedio de los principales
países miedo en Perú las empresas
mineras pagan más de lo que es habitual
en países como Canadá Australia Chile o
Estados Unidos entre otros muchos
tan solo entre los años 2009 y 2019 las
empresas mineras en Perú pagan en
impuestos 85 mil millones de soles unos
25 millones dólares al cambio de aquel
momento y ojo porque hasta que tenemos
que añadir el dinero salarios en
cotizaciones sociales y por contratos
con empresas locales así que si metemos
todo en la ecuación queda claro
meridiano que el Perú gana mucho
muchísimo más con las explotaciones
mineras que cualquier empresa que
explota yacimientos en el país vamos que
saque o saque o lo que se dice saqueo
pues como que no pero entonces porque
mientras las comunidades parecen no
avanzar porque muchos casos la población
local tiene sentimiento de que las
multinacionales se llevan los recursos y
ellos se quedan sin nada pues amigos
amigas justa que es cuando llegamos a lo
que se conoce como el canon minero
los entes subnacionales las regiones los
municipios y los distritos donde existe
actividad minera reciben cada año el 50%
de los ingresos recaudados por el Estado
para gastarlo en principio en inversión
pública junto al Cano minero encontramos
también el canon gasífero el petrolero y
las regalías mineras es decir que los
entes subnacionales te las zonas donde
se explotan los recursos naturales 3 SIM
en un montón de ingresos cada año
hablamos de más de 2000000 $ anuales
para regiones que por lo general son un
pobre a pesar de ello el descontento
social parece más que evidente
que por el bajo nivel de la clase
política peruana del que hablamos en un
reciente vídeo que os dejo en la
descripción lo gastan mal y eso cuando
consiguen gastarlo porque según datos
del mes entre 2009 y 2019 apenas logran
ejecutar poco más del 60% del
presupuesto disponible esto supone que
las principales regiones mineras se
dejan en el cajón más de 1800 millones
de soles anuales pagados por la
industria minera es decir para
entendernos que estos entes
subnacionales han acumulado miles y
miles de millones de soles en las
cuentas del Banco Nacional al tiempo que
su regiones carecen de todo tipo de
infraestructuras básicas y eso amigos
pues no es culpa de las minas sino de la
política
de sus nacionales no tienen que pedir
más recursos lo que se tiene que
trabajar es en cómo gestionar mejores
recursos el discurso de que las empresas
aportan muy poco que algunos afirman
desconoce el exceso de recursos que
tienen estas autoridades Miguel Castilla
director de videncia consultores en 2020
por la crisis del coronavirus el que no
fue mucho más reducido apenas
4504 millones de soles pues bien a pesar
de ello los gobiernos y municipio
subnacionales apenas ejecutará un poco
más del 50% de esta cantidad y luego a
la cantidad que logran gastar hay que
restar la corrupción antes veíamos por
ejemplo el caso de Cajamarca la región
más pobre del Perú y el lugar de Pedro
Castillo
[Música]
Cajamarca es una región de 1,3 millones
de habitantes donde casi el 50% de la
población vive en condiciones de pobreza
severa donde el 20% de las viviendas no
tienen electricidad el 26 % un no tiene
servicio de agua corriente y el 62 % no
están conectadas a redes de saneamiento
pues bien solo entre 2009 y 2018 que
esta región recibió del canon minero y
las regalías casi 1200 millones de
dólares para realizar inversión pública
de toda esta cantidad casi la mitad el
47% no se ejecuto no se gastó
y a pesar de ello casi el 30% del
presupuesto público de todos los entes
subnacionales de esta región se
financiarán con cargo al canon minero y
a las regalías amigos aquí en la minería
ilegal que evidentemente pues no paga
nada es donde está el gran problema y el
por qué tantos y tantos peruanos tienen
la impresión de que las mineras pagan
mucho menos de lo que realmente pagan
ahora bien llegamos a la última gran
pregunta qué consecuencias puede tener
castillo para el futuro de la minería
peruana atento
Australia o Venezuela
latinoamericana
amigos el desarrollo de las energías
verdes está disparando la demanda de
productos minerales de todo tipo
[Música]
en estos momentos el país andino
Pacífico y amazónicos una cartera de
proyectos mineros con inversiones
estimadas de casi 60000000 de dólares
proyectos que según estimaciones del
Instituto Peruano de Economía podrían
traducirse en ingresos fiscales de miles
y miles de millones de dólares durante
los próximos años
el problema es que muchas esporádicos
están frenados y para colmo la llegada
de Castillo con sus amenazas pueden
hacer que se enfren más esto es esto es
exactamente lo que se está jugando el
Perú
amigos las cosas en el pasado no se han
hecho muchos casos bien la dejadez de
muchas compañías la corrupción y la
incompetencia de los gobiernos locales
han ralentizado el desarrollo del país
pero eso son cosas que se pueden
solventar pero un necesita inversión y
la industria minera tal y como ocurre
por ejemplo en Australia puede ser un
gran motor de prosperidad en cualquier
caso llegamos hasta aquí turno para ti
impacto crees que puede tener la llegada
de castillo para la industria más
importante del Perú cumplirá sus
amenazas con finalmente será mucho más
pragmático de lo que parece déjanos tu
respuesta por aquí abajo los comentarios
y ya sabéis si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros al político un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]